hello my name is ko JA karate and my the
title of my presentation is speech
analysis processing and sentences I will
talk about upcoming functionality in
Mathematica relating to speech mainly
classification and processing
the first thing I want to show is
actually the last thing in the list the
synthesis we have upgraded our speech
synthesize function to get slightly
better quality results and wider away
all of voices so just yeah Wow okay
forget this everything with his some
serious problem there whoops sorry about
that let's see if this works without too
much effort haha yes so this is one
example golden key in lock into her
great delight it fitted okay so we have
improved our we'll see how this goes on
we have improved the range of voices and
we have improved the quality of the
synthesis we do now accept all the
options the spoken string takes so you
can actually have an audio object of
Mathematica a generic Mathematica
expression not only a string about
analysis and processes one function that
we're becoming is speech or synthesized
so the general the general idea is that
you can parameterize a speech recording
into a limited set of parameters then
you can manipulate these parameters and
synthesize a signal from the result of
your operation so speech were
synthesized has a variety of modes of
operation we have some preset actions
for example pitch shifting you might say
so we already had the audio pitch shape
function does a fairly decent job this
is the original signal right then
perfect timing and Here I am just
shifting by five semitones down
Water Bridge diamond now what happened
here is that the whole signal has been
shifted down not only the fundamental
frequency of the speech but also all the
firmaments the Furman's are frequencies
that depend on the physical
characteristics of your vocal tract and
and your whole vocal apparatus I guess
so what you really want to do is to
shift the fundamental frequency of the
signal but keep this formant information
intact and this is what speech are
synthesized can do rather than perfect
timing and it is lower in tone now right
then
perfect timing but as you can hear the
voice is rather
perfect timing all the pitch change
without changing the characteristics of
the voice similarly for time stretching
this does change and similarly you can
do the same with speech synthesized I
mentioned before that you can shift the
fundamental frequency without affecting
the firmance so what about instead of
just shifting the four months without
affecting the fundamental frequency so
what I want to do is maintain the pitch
at which these words are was being
spoken but I will shift the voice
quality this is something that was
impossible before in the language so I
won't guarantee the result well sound
particularly I'd bet rightly perfect
time okay this is a fairly Nokia shipped
but if we do something slightly more
dramatic right perfect timing
the pitch is maintained by the quality
of the voice is completely changed now
these are presets they can get all very
easily the nice thing about synthesized
is that we are designing a sin
that allows more user customizable
operations in this case and you can
operate on the various components namely
the fundamental frequency of the signal
the spectral envelope of the signal and
the a periodicity component of the
signal so here I am doing a targeted
modification to the fundamental
frequency perfect timing and you can
write whatever kind of pure function to
do these kinds of modifications if you
want to dig deeper into what is going on
we are planning so this function is
experimental I will not promise the
design will be exactly the same when it
will be released but we will will have a
way of grabbing all these parameters and
let the use of manipulate them so here I
am asking for the speech or synthesized
data of our initial signal as you can
see the information I get is fundamental
frequency spectra line the loop a
periodicity and then some just
parameters for how to build up the
synthesis again and the convenient thing
is then you can inspect this parameter
so speech synthesizer is not only a tool
to get a second audio signal out it's
also very good to to do analysis of
speech signals so this is how a
fundamental frequency signal looks like
we can look at spectral envelopes and we
can look at the a periodicity component
so this gives us information as I said
about the four months of the signal and
this gives information about the
transient they appear non periodic
transients that happen on a consonant
like sounds and we can manipulate all
this information and just put it back
together and get back right perfect time
in this case so just a quick mention of
our speech recognition we will have a
function that does that
at the moment the current implementation
is seriously lucky lacking and we will
have a much better implementation based
on neural networks but the timeline for
that is a bit longer again I will not
promise exact dates but it is in the
works to have some very good speech
recognition function so other things
that you could do about analysis and
processing of speech signals is using
some functionality that was already in
the system for example audio local
measurements so I don't know if you are
aware of the vowel diagram here we
display several vocalic sounds and the
position in this two-dimensional space
is very much defined by the position of
the firmance which as i said of these
resonances of our vocal tract so what I
will do here is first grab the
collection of these recordings e
eccentric cetera and i will use audio
local measurements to compute these
formants as you can see here is it's
enough to specify that I do want the
formants corresponding to a signal and
let's see if this works this is a sure
effect except of them as you can see
it's two formant frequencies which is
what we need to reproduce this diagram
and our goal is to reproduce it
programmatically so we don't know
anything about what is
vocalic sounds that we just know formant
frequencies and we can plot them this
might take a little while play a lot of
audio object and so let's see if the
distribution that we got here actually
and is similar so a top left e we do get
an e and here x1 so we kind of produce
this kind of sound
or a and yeah as you can see we have
reproduced in a completely programmatic
way without any knowledge about
phonetics the vowel diagram a new
function that is coming is audio
distance and here the idea is a measure
of how similar two signals are so here I
have a collection of recordings of the
first sentence of Alice in one Alice was
beginning to get very was beginning to
get very tough Alice was beginning to
get Alice was beginning to get very
tired have a very different voices and
they have a very different positive
which is how fast they are reading
essentially well not exactly but that is
one of the factors and I will compute
here a distance matrix of all the
signals by using audio distance and I
will use inside on your distance I will
use a warping distance which is the sum
distance distance measure that will take
into account a variation on the specific
timing of the signal and this will give
me information about which signals are
more similar in this case I can see that
signal 1 and signal four are the most
different Alice was beginning to get
very tired Linda speaks fairly quickly
sitting by her sister on the bank and
male this big slowly the second one is
also very different from the first one
instead the two most similar ones the
second and the fourth which are I guess
the two male speakers so this can give
us some insight into not only speech
signals but generic signals and now just
as a nice visualization I am computing
the distance matrix between all the data
in our audio example
collection and this will give us
information about which samples are the
most similar to each other it doesn't
give any quantitative quantitative
information at the moment but it is nice
visualization in this case of our audio
data example collection now a lot of
analysis and processing these days as
you have seen I'm sure in this
conference can be done with machine
learning and we are significantly
improving our machine learning framework
and in the sense that now having all you
as an input rather than images of text
numbers will be fairly straightforward
so here I have a data set of recordings
of specific commands like no yes down
etc except something that if you were to
build a small robot and you would try
and control it with your voice this
could be some commands that you would
like for your elbow to be able to
recognize so yeah oh so fairly
straightforward you can imagine how this
down etc etcetera just note you know the
machine learning examples I will give I
will use this kind of ugly utility
function to extract some features from
the audio signal now what we are
planning to have in 11:3 is an audio net
decoder that will be incorporated in the
neural networks without the using the
user having to worry about this so it
will be much more streamlined
essentially so what I will do here is I
will compute the mal spectrum which is
kind of a nonlinear remapping of the
usual spectrogram
I will compute this picture on each of
the input samples these are interested
the parameters that will be used but
probably a more practical way to look at
this is to look at some plots of these
male spectrums so the vertical axis here
is time and the horizontal axis is
frequency so sure this is a bunch of
example features that the neural network
will see so what I do is construct a
simple neural network it just has this
if you are wondering what are the
reasons why I chose this architecture
this is an architecture that has worked
very well for image processing tasks and
given that the input I am I am feeding
to the network is a two-dimensional
matrix I end up using the same
convolutional structure that is very
fast and produces very good results in
image processing I will skip the
training part which nonetheless didn't
take too much time on my machine so this
is something that if you download the
data set which is I think several
gigabytes it still took no more than
half an hour on my machine
only CPU not GPU to train so this is
something that every one of you could do
locally without having to go on clouds
and stop buying a GPU or stuff like that
so as I said I will skip the training I
will import the beta in that and I can
look at the results you might take a
little white or compute ok and as you
can see just with half an hour of
training on this machine without any
fancy stuff the network is very basic
you could definitely come up with a more
component model I still get very good
accuracy so this is validated on the
training data and this is the result of
the validation on death data that the
network has never seen I get a 90%
accuracy
and as you can see most of the mistakes
is the network misclassifies any input
to the other category and which is
firmly understandable all the other
classes correspond to a single world the
other class correspond to every other
world so that is the main source of of
ever in the network so as I said this is
an easy way to do some machine learning
on audio and it is possible on your
laptop without any additional effort and
you could expert the resulting train
network to run on small devices
another example still in the machine
learning kind of thing is speaker
separation so this is a very tiny data
set this is a more proof-of-concept
example rather than something you would
use and it has spoken digits and the two
labels in the data set are with digitus
is being spoken and which speaker is
pronouncing the digit so in this case
even have the class and still Nicolas we
have only three speakers unfortunately
as I said that the size of the data set
is very tiny so what I will do here is
compute the male frequency sep stock
coefficients for all the data set and
this is about I think 600 files on my
house I am computing it now and this is
done so this is what we will be adding
in the net encoder function you could
use that to batch convert a bunch of
audio files that you have on your hard
drive on to features in this case mal
frequency sets are efficient this is
still for those of you who don't know
you still get a two dimensional image
per each audio signal and if you want to
look how this look like it's kind of
similar to the null spectrum but the
information is kind of
mango all around so what can we do with
this we want to classify these and by
the way this information was just
extracted by the training data so what
we can do is just use classify feeding
just this Norfolk with frequency surf
style coefficients directly to classify
it the user doesn't have to do anything
know anything and classify will do the
thinking for us let's look at the
information about classifier as you can
see this classifier that was chosen
automatically by the system as using
gradient boosted trees if any of you
know it's exactly what it is I don't
really know but you can see it gets a
very good accuracy on our training set
now let's see how this despairs on the
training data eighty-four percent so
sure it could be improved but with
essentially zero effort from the user we
still get a very good prediction by
classifying now how can we what is
potential strategy to get better results
at this so what we could do is of course
train another network but in this case I
wanted to try something slightly
different I will show you what the
example is oops not that Wow
still not good so if there are some
problems with the batch files being
small sorry about that
anyways the idea is that I grab two
random samples in my data set and I
attach the label which is true with the
speaker is the same or false as the
speakers are different so now I am not
telling the network ok this input
belongs to this speaker this other input
belongs to the southern speaker I am
just telling these two are the same or
these two are different so this is the
input data for my problem for my new
problem and what I do is I define a
single speaker nut that is exactly this
that we looked at for the speaker
commands so this takes one speaker as an
input but then what I do using that net
map operator I map this NAT onto the two
empires that I was talking about and
then I want to classify if this is to us
or false the crucial part here is that
the branch that looks at the first
speaker on the branch that looks as the
second speak speaker are exactly the
same network they share the same weight
so in the training it's not like this
will learn one speaker this one will a
different thing they are exactly
synchronized at every step so this is
the final network so this is the
operation that lives inside it that is
mapped on the two inputs I will also
here skip the training and import the
printer in net and we can learn how this
goes how this fares in terms of
recognizing these two speakers of the
same or not very well of course on the
training data slightly as well on the
testing data so what was the overall
goal of this just to say if speakers are
different know what I can do is now I
can extract the net that was processing
one of the two inputs and use this as a
feature extractor for my recordings as
you can see this is read in normal
convolutional layer some convolutional
layers but the output is not a class
it's a vector of 100 elements and what
we hope is that this vector of 100
elements manages to capture some of the
characteristics of the speakers while
leaving behind the information on what
is being spoken and what was done during
training is a set of test features from
the three speakers were monitored so via
the output of the net on a set of test
features
was monitored as a function of the
training time so we start with a fairly
random distribution so that the various
colors belong to the values speakers so
yellow is one again is another blue is
the tab as I said this was a 100 long
vector this has been reduced in
dimension with dimension reduced to 2d
so we can plot it in a two-dimensional
space at the beginning all of the
speakers are completely intermixed but
we can see that as the training
progresses the three speakers are
clustered in different areas of the 2d
plane and we end up if we fast-forward
to the end you can see that there is a
very nice separation about the green
speaker of the yellow speaker and the
blue speaker now we can use these
features that we have extracted this 100
like vector as a new input for
classifying so I am doing just that
computing the result of this net' onto
the input that we looked at before if
you want an example we can get a random
sample of these features it's a
collection of 100 length vector that
goes to a label that identifies the
speaker and we can run classify again
onto this data same parameters
performance goal quality if we look at
the classifier information now we get an
accuracy of 100% of course on the
training data now we can compute some
test features and work at how this
classifier now behaves on data that it
has never seen okay not 100% but still
about 10 percent better than the
classifier that we used that didn't have
this nice feature extractor that we
built so this is how by merging
and a custom neural network and and
completely automatic classifying
can be used applied to speech and audio
related problems how is it thank you for
listening this is the team that has been
working on the audio processing singing
side
[Applause]